what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
today i will be announcing my giveaway
and be unboxing some marvel avengers
chairs by anderseed and thank you to
antacete for sponsoring this video and
sending the chairs
i know a lot of people have been
wondering what the giveaway is while
andesite has been so generous to provide
one of their avengers chairs to you you
get to choose your own
one of the four that i'm about to unbox
antecede makes the best chairs
in the industry now they're partnered
with marvel i'm going to unbox them in
this video and talk about what
makes them so good and worthy for a
superhero to sit in
all right so the first chair i'm going
to be opening is the spiderman chair
which is
a little bit above the others it has a
little bit better
leather
is the spider-man no way home trailer in
here
i hope i release this video before it
comes out otherwise this is
oh man dude this is cool
what whoa
this okay this is cool can i take it oh
man
look at that oh that is cool
oh this is cool all right i gotta get
this puppy out of here
cutting it open oh wait there we go
i'm cutting it open anyways
do not cut the leather
all right
oh it's
okay it's a lot cooler than i thought it
was going to be it actually really is
and this
is wow
wow
and a seat well they know how to do it
they know how to do it this is fantastic
i'm gonna put this right here
and let's get the rest out oh yeah look
at that
little headrest pillow little spidey
action
all right that's nice
oh that's like it's got a freaking
buckle on it
look at that
wow that's super cool all right
you know this kind of looks like webbing
i know it's not i know i know it's just
protection
but that a plus surprise
this is super super sturdy
oh yeah that's made super well nothing
but the best for man to see
these guys are awesome look at that all
right what do we got here
oh this is the pad that the wheels go on
awesome
okay that's just fun that's just nice
because some of these wheels have a real
hard time moving on carpet yeah
look at that no way
that's so cool oh that's super cool
that was super clever that's awesome
okay and then here's the lumbar support
look at this
marble right there that's pretty good
oh yeah that's nice
it smells good that new leather smell
man wow
that's okay
that's a big chair this is like this is
a big chair
all right so here's all the parts and
stuff that we're about to do
yeah this sure might have been my room
it might be too big for me i'm only five
seven
i'm a short guy
which is why i would be the perfect
wolverine i'm just sick
all right uh can you pick up the
box you might do this let's bring this
out
sweet
this is a big chair man this is big
it's really big all right we're gonna do
instruction oh
there oh that's nice oh it goes
it goes back and forth oh
he's got so many adjustments
oh thank you and a seat oh yeah
oh yeah okay there's going to be some
instructions in here
let's do this
all right let's build a spiderman chair
one of four
instructions
i mean it seems pretty straightforward
if you've built the chair before
it's got pretty much the same stuff it's
just built a lot better right so first
things first
we're putting this guy on top
maybe not okay that one stays the same
that one's not supposed to move okay put
that there
we're gonna save these for last
oh wait like all right after putting the
mechanism on it just the wheels
super simple put them right in
a little bit of pressure
simple put the mechanism in it
and we're good to go then you put it on
what are the odds of your news not hot
double ship this part anyways because we
didn't do it the right way
and that's the spiderman chair
all right oh wait we're missing we're
missing a couple parts
lumbar sport gotta have a little more
support
marvel
and oh yeah
oh yeah that's a great looking chair now
and a seat chairs are
top of the line they're the best of the
best they started with a history of
manufacturing racing car seats for bmw
and mercedes-benz and right now they are
dominating the esports community
used by many esports professional teams
such as fnatic
lgd ahq victorious gaming and even more
than that that's pretty nice it's got a
ton of different
up down sideways like this
back and forth look at that go back and
forth
and go side to side
it's got so much you can position this
thing
exactly as you want look at that all
right
holy grail oh
oh oh oh oh oh that's nice
oh wow
get my pillow up here oh
oh look at that control all right i
wanna
does this this one
that's so nice this is a chair
this is like wow
that's a spider-man chair we got three
more
all right this is the iron man one and
since it's the iron man one i
kind of have to do this
it's kind of like necessary
ant-man captain america
i know a lot of people are gonna want
this one
now besides these chairs basically being
the coolest chairs i've ever seen in my
life
they are super ergonomic and great to
sit in the captain america iron man and
ant-man chair is made out of a d
plus pvc leather and the spider-man
chair is ad alpha linen fabric which is
used on their high
end chairs each chair is scratch and
stain resistant
padded with cold cured and super high
density foam comes with
ad memory pillows which supports your
back and your neck and is by far the
most comfortable chair i've ever sat in
that's super awesome all right
that's really cool
all right
well that's an ironman chair
that's cool
look at that
all right
yeah oh god um
all right
oh that's some lumbar support
oh yeah
these are awesome look at these
these incredible the leather
from the to the floor mat i mean
everything the lumbar support
the neck rest the ability to just
to change everything these are the best
chairs you can possibly get
hands down after feeling these after
sitting in them they are the best chair
that you could get
so if you would like a chance to win one
of these just click the link in the
description down below
you can go to gleam.co we have the
giveaway set up do everything on there
to enter
and you get to choose which one you want
and andeseed is going to send you one
directly to your house i think i'm going
to go with the iron man one
i think it's what i'm going to use for
my every day
thank you again to anderson for these
awesome cheers and giving one
away to my awesome subscribers love you
all these are the best cherries you can
get
woof